yeah welcome to this video playing Jimmy
the saint from Egypt yeah that's Egypt
yep so let's see I have played six games
against him before and it's a 15-percent
score so pretty evenly matched no draws
though okay taking a while after a six
maybe he wants to exchange and it's not
quite sure okay went back to it for so
let's play normal main line or something
else yeah I'm playing the normal main
line okay let's let's play the Braille
not go for my my old she going again
yeah people have asked how my new mouse
is doing yeah doing all right I'm
adjusting and still sometimes make him
yeah involuntary adjustments on it yeah
by pressing one of those buttons and
that's like 20 buttons or something and
then I don't know some said some setting
has changed all of a sudden during a
game which screws up the whole thing but
it's not it's not a huge issue okay it's
going be three so probably he wants to
he wants to play D 5 D 5 c64 I don't
mind that much having good I mean good
um experience with this type of
structure I can also go see 5 now let's
do that why not c5 looks fine here
grabbing some space you know what I'm
just thinking about he might have
something like a form
and Bishop d3 okay maybe it's an idea to
play the bishop back to see eight and
then to d7 covering that yeah here here
he goes hmm yeah that's a bit I don't
like that too much Bishop might come to
d3 and Bishop c8 looks like a strange
movie and this position but okay if he
takes and we exchanged everything it
shouldn't be and that bad yeah I don't
have much experience with this type of
pollution normally I if I play this this
brand set up I quite often played with
c6 not with c 5 which is probably worse
objectively but at least it's something
that I have a bit of experience with and
here I'm kind of reinventing the wheel i
guess but still I can go Bishop d7 night
c 7q b5 covered this Bishop won't be too
isn't exactly great either now it should
be okay I think Bishop to d7 and
possibly like queen bee aid yeah let's
go there a queen bee 8 queen bee 7
rookie aid or something like that it's a
slowish type of scituate side up slowish
type of position Wow ya doing those
early recordings sometimes it's true
it's tricky for me a google tongue
twisted yeah I just want to go look
aight trade this rook okay yeah that's a
fairly typical way to set it up
for wide so I don't know the question is
do I place afore i do I take taking has
some points actually huh not sure about
this okay I'm putting putting it to c4 I
had simply have more experience with
this type of position from my Chi Goren
but this is already a version of this
chicken that is pretty good because his
pieces are not really well placed them
he's totally I mean it's very far away
from ever playing at for let's say I was
just quite often a key idea this Bishop
won't be too was a bit misplaced and he
doesn't really have a clear clear way
forward I'm going Luke a eight next and
get the rooks off usually when rooks are
traded I feel like I'm pretty much out
of the woods if the rooks are gone I
have more freedom to maneuver for
example something like Bishop e7 to d8
to be 6 is an idea something that should
be mentioned as that he's taking like
ages for this I really don't know what
is the problem maybe as a connection
issue or something that's really far
beyond anything reasonable having spent
three minutes twenty here I mean this is
mostly like theory on very M
conventional moves so some bit strange
what what took him so long down
yeah my idea is to get the bishop to d8
to be six i also had g6 Bishop h6 that's
also a good idea but the bishop won't be
six is really a nice nice piece so I'm
going to go for that
yeah you cannot go night everyone down
because of the e4 pawn hanging so let's
see I can actually grab the FR now maybe
so no reason no reason not to possible
Queen a3 is interesting after the
bishops are being traded which is a very
likely scenario in fact the most likely
scenario here said I just weaned on time
I really do it over to Sky's doing
probably it's some technical issue ok so
the night here and then Bishop to b6
yeah that's a very common way to play
with I don't really mind it much like my
king position is totally safe so no
worries them ok i can go Queen a7 if I
like to try to weaken this position a
little bit I don't know if I should
though yeah maybe maybe how is he
covering that let's do it maybe night to
each one something that looks strange
but how is he covering the pond
yeah that so that was necessary i guess
so now let's get this night back into
the game yeah i think 98 m just tend to
be ready to recapture with the night and
i also have the Queen invasion now so
Queen to a three or something let's see
I can also take you for by the way I can
take you for you you neglected the cover
of this pawn plus the the time is she of
course yeah it seems that she has some
quite substantial connection issues so
what now I can just take it I just
retreated d5 is the next weakness like
four fins on time yeah there was a
strange game strange game because of the
the time issues yeah i think i think the
the question for me is if we think about
this position here how big of a problem
is this is a big issue for black i'm not
really sure this looks decidedly
unnatural but take stakes and not sure
that Roux kade is the best the computer
wants to play this move after which i go
here maybe now Bishop d3 by the way that
that would have been interesting how I
didn't really appreciate that the
compass giving this move and says black
it's okay yeah maybe he can mean he rly
this in no position to take the pawn I
always have those discovered moves and
this given us about equal by the comp
yeah maybe my experience as I said is a
bit
with this precise setup yeah yeah I'm
okay definitely the porn is safe I get
the rook trade and they're on the file
and I actually think that with this some
kind of peace configuration um white has
to be worried about equality here simply
because i get my bishop improved to be
six and then i have the pawn leave us
like f5 and things like that it's not
quite clear what what why it has i mean
okay he wasn't this huge time time time
problem so on he probably had to I mean
fighters his technical issues during the
game so it's hard to really am yeah
properly evaluate what happened because
it was pretty clear that i will win on
time in any case but i think black
doesn't have any particular problem p.m.
after the first ya like like around here
i think it should be it should be fine
okay well thanks for watching